la première rencontre avec le métier de
boucher je les ai eus à l'âge de 8 ans
un boucher de campagne qui venait à la
ferme de mes parents pour abattre et
découper un animal pour notre propre
consommation
j'ai tout de suite été fasciné par ses
gestes ses gestes quelques années plus
tard je les ai appris à l'école de la
boucherie et puis à l'âge de 19 ans ma
passion pour ce métier m'a permis de
convaincre un banquier de devenir
entrepreneur et d'avoir ma propre
boucherie alors 19 ans c'est très jeune
pour autant de responsabilités mais ça
m'a permis d'entrer dans ce métier avec
un esprit neuf et innovateur et je me
suis mis tout de suite a imaginé le
stack idéal et repenser tous nos
fondamentaux
on a tous une idée assez précise de ce
que doit être le steak idéal j'ai
beaucoup voyagé autour de la planète
pour comprendre notre monde carnivores
et finalement j'en ai déduit que la
définition de ce serait idéal est
universel qu'on soit de paris de londres
tokyo buenos aires sydney tout le monde
tout le monde veut un steak tendre et
goûteuse
tendre ça veut dire pauvre en collagène
le collagène c'est ce que vous avez dans
la bouche quand vous avez longuement
mastiquer un steak trop ferme et goûteux
ça signifie bien équilibrée en gras
rapporté aux boeufs
c'est un animal jeune et correctement
vrai c'est un peu comme moi de tous les
ingrédients alimentaires le steak est
peut-être le seul dont on ne peut dire
qu'il a de mon passé le meilleur steak
est à inventer avec toutes les
problématiques économiques écologiques
et sociales que nous impose le 21e
siècle et particulièrement en france
d'ailleurs
car en france on ne consomme le steak
depuis seulement la fin du 19e
contrairement aux anglais qui déjà au
xvième siècle faisait griller retire la
viande
les anglais ont inventé la vache que
l'on mange et la vache qui produit du
lait c'est pragmatique en france nous
utilisions des races mixtes
la normande en normandie la montbéliard
dans l'est la salers en auvergne à elle
produisait le lait nécessaires à la
fabrication du fromage et les mâles les
boeufs travail et les chants les animaux
que nous mangions étaient des animaux
âgés que l'on consommait essentiellement
sur leurs lieux d'utilisation à la
campagne et qu'on faisait bouillir
c'est pour ça qu'on attend de plats
traditionnels en sauce en france le
boeuf bourguignon la garbure la
carbonade le pot-au-feu
mais aujourd'hui et depuis le début du
xxème la viande rouge est entré dans les
villes et s'est adressé à une population
qui n'a pas le même rythme de vie qui a
toujours eu l'habitude de retirer
griller la viande sauf que nos animaux
n'ont pas été conçues pour ce type de
consommation
ils sont arrivés sur le marché de la
viande par défaut ils n'ont pas les
caractéristiques idéales pour produire
un bon steak nos races à viande
traditionnels que sont la vache
charolaise
la blonde d'aquitaine la limousine
on vous a bien entendu j'ai dit la vache
et non pas le boeuf
car notre boeuf produit plus de
collagène que la femelle
conçu sur une idée de rendement
musculaire notre vache fait pas de gras
et pour lui donner le gras nécessaire au
goût on est obligé de la nourrir avec
une alimentation très riche et très
coûteuse pour notre éleveur c'est un
modèle absurde qui depuis plus de 50 ans
est soutenu par les subventions de la
pac
alors comment pourrait-on faire un bon
steak en france il est absolument
nécessaire que l'on repensé entièrement
notre filière
c'est pourquoi avec mon associé clarisse
prévost j'ai créé un programme de
formation pour qualifier les acteurs de
la filière viande de la vache jusqu'au
steak en passant par les éleveurs
les bouchers et bien entendu les
cuisiner pour produire notre steak idéal
il faut d'abord avoir une viande pauvre
en collagène ça veut dire que notre
animal doit être précoce
arrivé à l'âge adulte au comme l'angus
par exemple 24 mois contrairement à la
charolaise 50 mois et puis il nous faut
un steak bien équilibrée en gras alors
on pourrait s'inspirer des élevages
industriels américains comme les filles
de loth à me refaire et produire un
animal très polluant le fameux black
angus us un jeune bovin de 18 mois
hormone est gavé de soja mais on peut
aussi respecter la nature de l'animal et
son environnement et replacer la vache
dans son territoire
là où elle a toujours vécu et là où elle
sait se nourrir n'oublions pas que notre
vache et herbivores
c'est pourquoi en tant que boucher
j'ai initié de nouveaux élevages mon
steak idéal provient du croisement entre
une vache autochtones une simmental une
normande
une salaire parce qu'elle sait se
nourrir et faire un grade qualité avec
laird qu'elle trouve dans le pré est un
taureau qui arrivera à l'âge adulte au
et qui nous produire at on pas trop de
collagène comme l'angus l'ère ford ou le
short horn
ainsi nous obtenons un élevage inscrit
dans son paysage qui ne nécessite pas
une nourriture qui vient de l'autre bout
de la planète
un modèle économique vertueux pour notre
éleveur bien entendu éco-responsable et
de cette façon nous produisons le steak
idéal pauvres en collagène avec un bon
équilibre de grave
alors on a tous entendu cette semaine
les médias nous expliquer que manger
trop de steak ou vais donner le cancer
mais tout est affaire de mesures je vais
vous raconter une anecdote
l'été dernier je veux organiser un
barbecue chez moi j'invite quelques
copains leur dit si vous voulez venait
accompagner
je pensais pas que le message passe
aussi bien je m'attendais à recevoir 10
personnes et je vois débarquer 30
carnivores affamés sauf que moi je
n'avais que deux belles côtes de boeuf
j'ai donc décidé de faire des grands
plate salades que j'ai disposés un peu
partout et je suis allé dans un coin du
jardin discrètement cuire les côtes de
boeuf
je les ai coupés en fines lamelles et
petit à petit tout au long de la soirée
je suis venu les apporter aux convives
puis à la fin la soirée lui chantant dû
dire merci c'était très bon c'est
suffisant s'est régalée c'était parfait
il ya un écart phénoménal en train
japonais qui va considérer la viande
comme un condiment qui vient aromatisés
le riz et les légumes et celle d'un cow
boy texan qui reculera pas devant
importera use d'une livre on l'a dit
tout à l'heure en 2050 nous serons 10
milliards d'êtres humains
même avec plus ou moins 20% de
végétariens le modèle texan n'a aucun
avenir
aucun sauf bien sûr si on trouve une
planète pas trop loin on mettra des
vaches et un peu de soja
quant au modèle français les ministres
de l'agriculture successifs ont pour
l'or depuis bien longtemps abandonné les
subventions européennes au profit des
céréales et du maïs qui pourrit jamais
il est absolument indispensable que l'on
réguler notre consommation de viande en
fonction de ce que notre planète peut
produire les japonais mangent dans un
bol un bol ça leur permet de visualiser
la quantité d'aliments qu'ils ingèrent
au cours d'un repas un bol c'est la
taille idéale pour se nourrir
correctement dans une assiette plate
les dimensions sont un petit peu plus
vague vous devez savoir que la forme de
votre poing fermé représente le volume
de votre estomac
autant nous dire que la quantité
d'aliments que l'on assimile au cours
d'un repas ne doit pas trop excéder
cette dimension j'aimerais vous inviter
à choisir votre viande en fonction de
son goût et de sa qualité et non pas en
fonction de la taille qu'elle occupe
dans nos grandes assiettes
finalement un steak pourrait se
consommer les yeux fermés pour mieux en
capter son goût sa jutosité ses mystères
et faire de vous un être bien vivant je
vous remercie